Welcome to the presentation on
more advanced ratio problems.
Let's get started
with some problems.
So let's say that I have a
class, and then-- oh the pen is
messed up --OK, so in the class
the total number of
students is 57.
And I would also tell you
that the ratio of girls
to boys is equal to 4:15.
So now this the interesting
part, so far it
doesn't look to tough.
My question is how many boys
need to leave the room, so how
many boys need to leave for the
ratio of girls to
boys to be 4:11.
This is fascinating.
So, a good place to start is
just to figure out how many
girls and how many boys there
are in this classroom.
And we already learned how to
do that in the introduction
to ratio problems.
We know that the girls plus the
boys is equal to 57, right,
because there are 57
kids in the room.
And we also know, just
multiplying-- taking this
equation --and multiplying both
sides by b, we also know that
the girls are equal to 4/15
times the boys, right?
And then we can just substitute
that back into this equation,
and then we get 4/15b plus b is
equal to 57, is the same thing
as 19/15b is equal to 57.
Let me clean this
up a little bit.
That's separate, and
then let me go here.
And we say b is equal to 57--
oh, woops --it's actually 57
times 15 all of that
over 19, right?
I just multiply both
sides by 15/19.
So 57 divided by 19 is 3.
So b is equal to 45.
And we know there're a total of
57 kids in the class-- g plus
b is 57 --so we know that
there are 12 girls, right?
57 minus 45.
Good.
So now we know that the
current boys and girls
are 45 boys and 12 girls.
So let's write that down.
So there's 12 girls
and 45 boys.
Now, the question says, how
many boys need to leave for
the ratio of girls to
boys equals 4 4:11?
So this is the number of
girls right now, 12,
this is the number boys.
Let's say x is a number of boys
that need to leave the room.
So if x boys leave the room the
new ratio will be 12 girls to
the 45 boys minus the x
boys that leave, right?
If that confuses you, sit and
look at that for a second.
We start off with 12 girls
and 45 boys in the room.
And we're saying x boys are
going to leave, so the new
ratio is going to
be 12:45 minus x.
And we know from this part of
the problem that that new
ratio is going to equal 4:11.
There, we just set up a
equation with one unknown
and we can solve for x.
I hope that doesn't
confuse you much.
All we did is we figured out
how many boys, how many
girls are in the room now.
We said x is the number
boys that need to leave.
And we said the new ratio is
going to be girls to the new
number of boys, which is 45
minus x, and that's going to
be equal to the new ratio.
So let's solve for x.
Well, 12 times 11 is
what that's 132.
132 is equal to 4 times
45, 160, 180, minus 4x.
And then if you solve for x, I
think you know how to do this
right now, and we can say minus
4x is equal to minus 48.
x is equal to 12.
There we solved it.
So we say that if 12 boys left
the room, the new ratio of
girls to boys would be 4:11.
And does that make sense?
Well if 12 boys left the room,
then the new ratio of girls to
boys would be 12:33, right?
Because 45 minus 12 is 33.
And that's the same thing
as if you divide the
top and bottom by 3.
That's 4:11.
So there, we got it right.
So what looked like a very hard
problem actually wasn't so bad
when you just sit down and
work through the algebra.
Let's do another problem.
Let's say --this thing
sometimes malfunctions --OK,
let's say that the ratio of
apples to bananas in a
basket is equal to 5:19.
And when we add 23 bananas the
ratio of apples to bananas--
and actually let's write it
right now, we now have 23
bananas more --is
equal to 10:61.
So the question is, what
is the total amount of
fruit in the basket?
Amount of fruit-- --ah,
that's so messy --after
adding the bananas.
So I actually gave you a
hint just when I wrote
down initial problem.
We're saying the ratio of a to
b-- so let a equal the number
of apples, and b equal the
number bananas --so the ratio
of apples to bananas
equals 5:19.
When I add 23 bananas, now the
new ratio's going to be the
number of apples to b plus 23.
The new ratio is 10:61.
So how do we solve this?
Well, once again we have two
equations and two unknowns.
We know that-- I guess let's
take this equation first,
because it's a little more
complicated --we know if we
cross multiply that 61a is
equal to 10b plus 230 and if we
divide both sides by 61, we
know that a is equal to
10/61b plus 230/61.
Right?
And we could take this equation
and multiply both sides by b
and we could say that
a is equal to 5/19b.
Right?
Well both of these are equal
to a so we could set them
equal to each other.
And you get 5/19b is equal to
10/61b plus 230 times 61.
And we solve for b.
While this might seem
complicated to you at first,
but it's just a basic
linear equation.
And for the sake of time,
because I only have 2 minutes
left in this youtube.
I'm just going to solve for b,
and you get b is equal to 38.
if b is equal to 38, we know
that the initial ratio is 5:19.
So that's pretty easy.
We just say a is equal to 5/19
times 38 is equal to 10.
So the initial number of apples
was 10, the initial number
bananas is 38, right?
So initially we started off
with 48 pieces of fruit, and
then we're going to add 23
more pieces of fruit, right?
And 43 plus 28, that's
what, 71 pieces of fruit.
So, let me review real
quick what we said.
We said the ratio of apples
to bananas is 5:19.
That's a is the number
of apples, b is the
number of bananas.
When I add 23 bananas, I now
have b plus 23 bananas, the
new ratio of apples to total
number bananas is 10:61.
And I just used both
of these equations.
Two equations and two unknowns.
Solved for a, and then
substituted, and
I solved for b.
Nothing fancy here.
I know there's a lot of
fractions here, but if you
just work through this, the
fractions actually work out.
And I was able to
solve for a and b.
Add the 23 pieces and I got
71 total pieces of fruit.
I think you're now ready
to try some of the more
difficult ratio problems.
Have fun!